a game that we hope does not get delayed
again Mass Effect Andromeda what's going
on with this game scary yeah what do you
guys think jakey won't you didn't seem
optimistic today hold sorry really quick
just primary go Aaron Flynn studio
manager at Bioshock bioware Edmonton
said march twenty first release date
2016 of this year Mass Effect Andromeda
is coming and that is the release date
as of now but we are wondering what is
going to happen with that because all
throughout the development process of
this game there's been studio departures
there has been you know like rumors
about development crunch getting to
people much like it sounds it was a case
with scalebound or any game nowadays it
seems like Mega Man Legends through and
now we're kind of wondering what is
going on Mass Effect Andromeda is it
being rushed I think a lot of footage
we've seen has not really comforted us
ah a lot of footage sorry sorry some
footy little footage some of the little
foot and the fact that there is only a
little footage the fact that we have
barely seen gameplay is worrying and
it's like two months away what's going
out with this Jake is pretty worried I'm
I'm kind of worried I like they've had a
lot of time to work on this game they
were work on it for five years now at
least that's what they said recently why
so like is this game being rushed like
maybe not like maybe they could hit
March I don't think they will though
because like what you were saying how
like a lot of people have left a lot of
people are like dealing with stress and
like crunch time I think this game has
changed a lot over the last couple years
and now they've kind of arrived on their
idea and they're like all right we need
to like get this done so I'm I think
it's gonna get the light you think it's
late I think it's gonna get the light I
hope it doesn't like I don't want to be
that one like everyone like if it gets
late everyone's like all you're the one
like I don't see that guy I don't wanna
be that guy but I think it's gonna be
delayed and like like you were saying to
we haven't seen much gameplay like we
have finally seen gameplay and what
we've seen looks pretty mediocre no come
on meet me up mediocre okay you know
what they haven't shown Jake they
haven't any of the dialogue stuff they
showed a little bit of it did it wasn't
that good right like I mean it was
what's
word for not that good it was Ed ochre
it was a huge improvement over like mass
effect 3 mass effect 2 but I mean I've
I've played The Witcher a lot and could
like looking at like the dialogue that
you go through in The Witcher which even
then it's still kind of like it still
kind of like cheesy at times and like
kind of like technical there's like
little technical issues but then with
this it looked worse than that and it's
just kind of like I don't well it was I
don't know and III when they showed off
some stuff people were criticizing the
quality of the animations and they were
like oh well they're not done yet and
it's like but but wait a minute this is
your time to finally show the game
they're showing something that's not
done yeah but that if you extrapolate
that to the bigger picture what does
that mean that means everything is
probably problematic like I think if it
gets too late that's a good thing like I
do too so I'm rushing out a game if
you've got a great idea take the time to
finish it that's we're hoping but yeah
the whole cause for concern the last
year or so especially when we
interviewed Erin Flynn eva either the
day of or the day before they showed
that footage III this year they're
saying they're rumors circulating that
they had to strip a lot of features
because they were trying to do too much
initially and then he gave them this
hard deadline so who knows how long
Bioware has known it was March 21st i
wonder if I told him that like last year
or something I met all these primers of
a departure 1 i'm sure they did but
Aaron Flynn said oh I didn't hear about
those rumors and whatnot very
misdirection but I'm a lot of you Mike
you're right this game is in horrible
why else would there major people leave
what is going on with this maybe you
know they always say no we just the
games in good shape everybody who left
of course they had that statement saying
this game is in great shape why why show
us this person scanning a room this is
all to bring in the makeup though who
cares it's a car I don't mean to get on
this guilt I don't looking for I don't
want it right that's just it you hope
it's good you're looking forward to the
chance that it's good but like I think
in the past Mass Effect games you could
watch some of the stuff they were
showing and say this game looks great
with this all you can say is I hope this
is great so yeah I mean and I think
that's what it comes down to like this
like the like nothing multiplayer the
gameplay I think the combat looks pretty
good it's like I order down vanquish
though does it I mean it looks like it
improved okay relatively compared to
Mass Effect 3 I mean yeah okay it's I I
don't think it's going to be incredible
but
that's never the point I mean I feel
like I shouldn't even say it's not the
point because I just have a good game
but like the gameplay wasn't what made
the game great right in my opinion yeah
but yeah I mean like what you were just
saying like seeing mass effect 3 singh
mass effect 2 singh Mass Effect 1 I was
blown away and then I see this and I was
hoping to get that same feeling and I
was like all right well I'll probably
play it and I hope I like it I hope it's
good right I'm not trying to be a
curmudgeon here it's just like really
telling this late in the game to see
just this amount yeah I know once played
it yet either right i mean like look
there's a similar problem with doom
where we didn't see a lot of that game
aside from multiplayer up until launch
and then it was like you know day of
release date review copies everyone was
nervous and holy [ __ ] that game ended up
being amazing that might be the case
here I totally could be but like in the
meantime what do we have to really go on
other than our hopes I mean even what
they showed at e3 it wasn't he just that
it looked bad I wasn't I there was no
reason to even show it was just a teaser
still yeah and that was 16 months ago
seven months ago I feel like they should
be they should be more on target by this
point because you know I said their
objective with it has to make a more
explorable kind of more homeless
seamless worse what I wanted I think
what a lot of people want to see like
how how does the the tempest get from
area to area like because they confirmed
you won't actually be flying the ship
but if it's supposed to be seamless than
like how is it seamless you just like
walk in your ship and walk around while
it flies there for you I don't know yeah
I mean you don't necessarily always want
to just hope a video game gets delayed
but I wouldn't be too surprised if it
happened I think you should hope I give
IDEO game gets delayed yeah if you're
wanting you to be good when you finally
died play it and hopefully gets
hopefully gets too late unless it's
because the team took a break and came
back and people said it wasn't worth
pursuing like scalebound or whatever it
supposedly happened I just hope it's not
like dragon age inquisition in space
because I know a lot of people like that
game but that game now is a lot people
don't like that good yeah I was not a
fan of that game in like almost looking
at some of those wide areas like I kind
of got that dragon age inquisition vibe
and I'm like no please don't do this
please don't do this yeah
I don't know so you think it's gonna get
the late Jake I think it's gonna get
delayed I hope it gets delayed but I'm
still very optimistic about it despite
what I said I I'm optimistic i think
it's gonna be good okay yeah i don't
think it's gonna be fantastic i don't
think it's gonna be like the next
witcher 3 for me but i think i'm gonna
enjoy quote i would be much less worried
if the past year and a half two years
wasn't just news about the studio people
huge people departing the studio and
leaving and like clearly the studio was
stressed out in the you know trying to
figure out what to do with this
franchise you know it's not gonna be
really connected to the first trilogy
too much you know aside from the name
and you know your characters in you and
everything it's a new galaxy so it's not
really connected at all but you know I'm
worried that maybe the weight of the
project there you know grasp it's
exceeded their reach are the other way
around grasp exceed their reach why not
both yeah I guess so maybe their reach
and their grasper too short anyway let
us know what you think about Mass Effect
Andromeda are you excited for it you
think it'll be good based on the
gameplay we've seen so far are you
worried about it do you think that
Bioware will pull through and release a
fantastic game let us know in the
comments below
[Music]